you look beautiful thank you sir
gorgeous yeah thanks for being here
i'm so happy to be here it's been a
really long time it has been let's just
hold hands
you moisturize like crazy i did i don't
at all and then i get reptile hands all
winter long
claws after all the flying i've been
kind of you know we've been flying let's
talk about this you've been flying
all over the world to promote anchorman
2.
it's been a crazy ride it's been an
insane ride i think i saw you
i was at a benefit where we i hosted the
the screening uh the reading cast
reading a lot of people don't know about
this that we what we did we did a
reading of the first movie so we all sat
down
with the entire cast entire cast this
huge audience and we just read the
script
and it was so much fun and you were so
amazing well what was nice was it raised
a lot of money for a good cause
i can't remember what it was
no idea but um but then tutoring to kids
for creative writing and things like
that for writing yeah it's very good
very good program
um i would never have done a jud apatow
movie again if i hadn't said that
because it's his
it's his charity yeah but you know what
i was interested in is that
i saw you just before you were all
leaving and then i started to see
pictures you were all going to do that
event and then literally get on playing
a plane and go all around the world to
ruin anchorman 2.
and i started to see these pictures of
you at different premieres like in
london
gorgeous picture of you at the london
premiere absolutely stunning
thank you but then i saw that picture
and i thought that's so beautiful but
then this is how the picture was picked
up in the british newspapers
look at that like
yeah yeah now that had nothing that had
nothing to do with you they just
happened to put
your picture but like i was really
confused because it said that
inbred's in the outback and then
underneath it said like a doctor who was
like
doing horrible things to his patients
and there's no mention of the premiere
yes they just put that picture in there
and then
50 off yeah something like that someone
asked me to sign that when i was in
london and i was like
oh i need to get a copy of this yeah
this is going into what's happened to
all of us
where you've had i mean i've had like a
picture of me at some event and then
they just put it somewhere
in an unimportant magazine but then the
headline which is for a different
article will say there are too many
idiots in america
and it's me going like that i think
i'm sorry sweetie i think that was your
headline
i did read it
it was a lot about me yeah staying a
little bit it's gonna sing a lot
all right holidays now are you getting
into it oh yeah
big big big holiday at our house this
christmas big time my daughter is losing
her mind she's like it's all about
santa and elves and things and presents
and how are you
hanukkah too someone said to her
yesterday happy holidays and she goes
and happy hanukkah kids are
kids are growing up very sensitive to
many cultures yes they are
uh what about christmas music is there a
lot of chris are you into christmas
music because i find that people are
very divided some people love it and
some people kind of can't stand it i
you know i can take it for a minute i
just i always like find like they're
they're the strange lyrics sometimes
that don't make any sense to me
like the one that that freaks me out is
i saw mommy kissing santa claus
because it she's such a skank right
i mean what a skank you know because you
know what i they used to confuse me
because i've had people later on explain
it to me but when i was
oh and how do they know the answer
because it's not in the lyrics there's
no indication that it's daddy
dressed up as santa claus no it's her
being a skanky
ho let me tell you something there's
there's a little known lyric that got
cut out
about her grabbing his balls oh no
that's not true not
true not true you can grab in santa's
balls
yeah yeah google it i'm telling you
right now
to hear you guys sing it i now
absolutely believe it yeah yeah sure
because you sing it so well the other
one is um it's cold
outside you know i don't i really gotta
go but baby it's cold outside and the
guy's being so creepy
right because she's like i have to go
and he's like it's cold outside
yeah you gotta stay and then at one
point there's a lyric where she said
what's in my drink right
there you go she does yeah what's in my
pocket what's in my dreams don't worry
about
it babe like let's say something like
let's let's smoke
something yeah it gets really weird a
little known lyric
where he talks about chaining her up
okay that's not
no not true not true that happened
not true i'll chain you up i tune you up
there's nothing you can do all right uh
we're gonna take a little break miles
away from where anyone can hear you